the last time she was here she told us
how much she loved
being a pen pal and she's a good one and
sends mail
so please welcome back the hilarious
beautiful
and ever so stylish saturday night live
cast member heidi gardner hi drew
okay what time is that heidi
dear drew
okay the first thing we do is announce
the zip code of the day
and in honor of you it's 64112
kansas city missouri my hometown
i was so excited to celebrate kansas
city
with you as we did at the news desk last
time and it's also the home of our
affiliate station
kshb channel 41.
hi guys so heidi what are some fun facts
about kansas city
okay well kansas city has over 200
working fountains
giving it the nickname of the city of
fountains so pretty cool
the country club plaza opened in 1922
it's the us's first suburban shopping
district
and every thanksgiving the plaza lights
ceremony happens
where a hometown hero flips the switch
to turn on the christmas lights
and i was so honored to have done it in
2019.
that must feel really good it's like
you know it sometimes in life something
tells you you're on the right track
yes it felt amazing it was like just a
sea
of kansas citians out there supporting
me to turn on lights it was really cool
okay kansas city missouri would you
please put pen to paper we would love
to hear from you please write us i don't
know how to describe it but there is
something life affirming
about mail yes and it's how it used to
be like
you get a letter in the mail you feel
special i mean look at this envelope if
that doesn't bring you
joy then you're dead inside
all right let's open our first letter
okay i am going to open it right here
dear drew i lost two jobs at the start
of the pandemic
so i've had to fall back on my art as my
only means of income
and therapy making my creations i call
them rimojis
has really saved my life the goal with
my art is to bring a smile to people's
faces
and i know you share the same sentiment
with your show
thank you that is the goal right emoji
um so as a thank you and hopefully to
bring a smile to your face i created
this
drew's news magnet as a gift for you oh
okay this is the cutest thing ever this
is so sweet and it does
bring a huge smile to ah there are
multiples
look at those look oh they're beautiful
by the way good blush yeah you look
great
um well rymoji i love
these and i'm gonna send you 2 500
that you can put towards just continuing
your passion
and doing what you do and just to say
thank you
and we recognize your work and admire it
very much
heidi your turn drew i love what you
were doing
so much so should we send another
twenty five hundred dollars yes
yes yes yes please please
thank you heidi oh thank you for
letting me share the love that's exactly
right
all right heidi um you have a letter
sent from one of your pen pals actually
i'd love you to share
okay
dear heidi thank you so much for
thinking of us and sending a card
we have a therapy dog named prada who
visits us
every saturday we miss seeing her and
can't wait until she can come back to
see us
we are also looking into therapy cats to
visit
your cat just had a birthday did your
cat enjoy his tuna birthday cake
we hope he enjoyed it from your friends
at seneca place verona pennsylvania
oh heidi that's so sweet i know
i know i love that all right we have
time for one more
hi drew barrymore i'm writing for some
advice ooh
i'm 20 years old and have never been on
a first date
it seems to me that you have been on
well over 50 first dates
so i need your help give me everything
you've got sincerely angie
all right um here's what i'm going to
say and it
actually is directly related to 51st
dates
the thing that i fell in love with that
story
was to me it was a great allegory about
someone who finds the energy to be kind
to someone every day and i think that
that is the epitome of a good
relationship
if you can find it in your heart to
muster up
kindness and patience and a sense of
humor and maybe even a sense of
adventure
on a regular basis that's what 50 first
dates is about and
when you go on your first date maybe
have that as an intention of someone
you're looking for
is going to be good to you on a daily
basis i love that
really it's just beautiful advice
for anyone for a married woman it's
beautiful
all right heidi do you have any advice
for angie
you know what i do have some advice for
angie um
you're 20 years old angie i bet you're
a wonderful young woman and i just want
you to encourage you
to be that young woman on your date just
have fun
and be you and and it's going to be
great
yeah yeah i love that advice it's so
true
well if you need any help or advice or
maybe you want to see something or try
something new
then mail questions requests photos and
heartfelt or funny stories
to find out more and get our address go
to drewberrymoreshow.com
deardrew well should we say it together
truly yours drew and heidi